new clothing inspired by historically
black colleges from one of america's
most iconic fashion brands the new
collection from ralph lauren draws on
the archives and the yearbooks of
morehouse and spelman colleges it leans
heavily on campus fashion from the 1920s
through the 1950s and the idea was
created by two ralph lauren employees
who are alumni of those schools and i
sat down with them to find out about the
source of their inspiration and their
dreams for what the collection might
represent
i have always believed in the american
dream
for over 50 years ralph lauren's line of
clothing has celebrated elegance and
style with the romanticized vision of
america
now its latest chapter of americana
perhaps overdue is a collection inspired
by the archives of two historically
black colleges and universities
featuring an all-black production team
and models from spelman and morehouse
colleges previously you know the way
that we showed collegiate style to the
world was really through
a white ivy league lens
alumni dora douglas and james jeter were
behind that collaboration they drew
inspiration from the clothing worn by
students attending hbcus throughout the
decades this was a love letter to
spelman and morehouse it was also a love
letter to all hbcus it was really more
about putting a spotlight on the
incredible style of individuals at these
hpcus in the 20s 30s 40s and 50s this
wasn't black style this wasn't white
style it was american style jeter
conceived the idea following the events
of summer 2020. in the wake of george
floyd's murder you were questioning
whether or not you even wanted to stay
here even though you'd spent your entire
career ralph lauren absolutely and you
know i think a lot of brands made
commitments in 2020 ralph lauren
included
but 2021 it's really about doing the
actual work none of my heroes looked
like me and i said that to ralph and
jeter says lauren listened though the
label historically included black models
like naomi campbell and tyson beckford
when other campaigns lagged on diversity
through the ages ralph lauren has been
seen as the paragon of ivy league prep
elite society and some have even said
waspiness but its creator was none of
those things he was a jewish kid from
the bronx when ralph lauren ralph
lipschitz started this company he was an
outsider himself exactly ralph didn't
grow up as a part of the ivy league
school so he made that world for himself
and he he built a dream what do you say
to people who will say well yeah there's
an opportunity to make some money here
it's so much bigger than again the the
money i think it's about a little girl
walking by a billboard and seeing
herself up in the sky how important is
it
to see yourself represented in these
spaces it's profoundly important
professor david wall rice was in the
campaign he says jeter's vision included
an open dialogue about complex issues
some historians who've said well this
clothing that the brand represents
is clothing that black people have had
to wear to occupy white spaces and if
anything this might be a way to simply
make money i think that's fair now one
of the things that i would say is that
as we're talking about how it is that
black folks show up in the world there's
no singular way of doing that in
suggesting how it is that black folk
have to wear clothes to do a certain
thing
i think that that divorces us from
agency while rice says black americans
have spent 400 years adapting and
finding ways to navigate the american
cultural landscape i'm thinking now
of du bois's classic uh note and
construct of double consciousness where
there is the black cultural
and there is also the american cultural
and in many times they're at loggerheads
these were some of the clothes that we
built america in we also picked cotton
and so we had clothing for that as well
and i think that this collaboration was
an effort of realizing us doing things
more boldly more fully and telling you
know more accurate stories and james
jeter says there are more chapters ahead
and so this is just the beginning ralph
has told so many stories
over the last 54 years but has so many
stories to tell
nice line so many bravos and kudos in
that story bravo to james and dara who
brought it to ralph's attention the fact
that they felt comfortable enough in
challenging him to say you know i'm not
so sure i want to be here and then big
bravos and kudos to ralph lauren who
listened right and said what can we do
about it and then really put out a
really beautiful gorgeous collection
james is 30 years old that's awesome you
know uh and dara is also fairly young
for ralph lauren a guy who's you know in
his 80s to listen to these two young
black employees that didn't have to do
anything and turned it over to them
turned it over to them so the the models
were people of color that's right the
photographers the whole production was
uh people of color and i should point
out i want to thank uh vita and and
jenny cayman our producer and miri
swarms first day back in the office
yesterday for mary she produced that
piece edited that piece really well done
it looked beautiful uh all well
beautifully done vlad yeah thank you